good evening everybody
um i'm tim franks i'm chairing the
debate
um wonderful to see the auditorium
packed i have to say that when i was
sent through the final wording for this
debate i thought how
appropriate it was not just because it
was interestingly worded but because
it was all in capitals
israel is destroying itself with its
settlement policy
if settlement expansion continues israel
will have no future
i know from my um three and a half years
reporting
from the region and the abuse i'm still
getting from my broadcasting that
there are few subjects which lend
themselves to such
shouty certainty and loudly
dogmatic diametric opposition as
israel and the palestinians and i dare
say a few of you
would have come here tonight already
stirred
by this provocatively titled motion
yes you'll say israel's settlement
policy is
fabulously self-defeating given that a
palestinian state is in israel's
best self-interest it undermines
israel's
own institutions its sacred institutions
its army its respect
for the judiciary its budget drainingly
expensive and it
increases international isolation and
tests
friends beyond patience or
perhaps you'll say
israel the jewish state is actually only
establishing
jewish homes in areas that
are historically traditionally jewish
a jewish settlement is actually the
west's
outpost against militant islam
they're not facts on the ground but
they're questions to be answered in
any future negotiations and
how about if the left was right
with all their gleamingly obvious
arguments why are they doing so
spectacularly badly in the opinion polls
all i ask is that as you listen to our
top-notch panel tonight
and you decide which way you're going to
vote i'm i'm instructed to
tell you how to vote i'm probably going
to get this wrong but i think you each
have a voting slip which says for or
against
when it comes to the moment when you
cast your vote
tear the voting slip in half if you know
that you're going to vote
for or against and put the relevant bit
in the box um
if you don't know if you still don't
know just
have the entire voting slip uh put in
the box
but anyway before you get to that moment
unclog your ears challenge
your preconceptions dare yourself only
to make up your minds when you've heard
all of our speakers so let's hear all of
our speakers
um first of all speaking for the motion
is william c card william is a
founder and chairman of forward thinking
an ngo
which works with the leadership of all
parties on both sides of the divide in
the israel-palestine conflict
in particular forward thinking has built
a close relationship with the
right-wing parties in the israeli
government coalition and with
hamas and islamic jihad in gaza
the west bank damascus and the diaspora
william thank you very much
[Applause]
well good evening everybody um i'm so
glad tim said
what he said because um i was going to
say that at the beginning as well
essentially the israeli-palestinian
conflict
provokes very very strong opinions and i
suppose of all the issues facing the
world
few will stimulate quite such a level of
intensity in public debate as this one
so i'm going to ask you tonight to try
for a moment to cast aside your
pre-held opinions whatever they may be
pro-israeli pro-palestinian
pro-neither pro-both um and
just try for a moment to put
that aside because i'm going to try and
argue this motion
as well as i can in in a non-political
way
partly because they know palestinians on
the panel partly because i'm not an
israeli and
the other three people on the panel are
i'm just a brit with the temerity to
have a view and also because my job in
conflict resolution requires me not to
take sides but just to try and be
pragmatic
and to try and identify the genuine
obstacles to
peaceful progress i'm going to argue
tonight that
israel's settlement policy is deeply
destructive to its own future for a
number of reasons
first by pursuing its policy of settling
what is now
over half a million israeli citizens in
the west bank
on land deemed by the international
community to belong to the palestinians
israel is making the world and even its
own allies believe
that it has no genuine interest in
making peace with the palestinians
secondly as a result of this settlement
policy
israel's support in the international
community is weakening
and it's leading to a the expression
delegitimization of israel and and
isolation of israel and i fear
ultimately onto a path of its
own destruction finally
i'm going to argue that even if israel
wanted to redress the situation
at a future date as part of a peace
agreement
the larger the number of settlements
built and settlers settled
beyond the so-called 1967 borders
the harder it will be for any israeli
government
to persuade its citizens to withdraw
from them
but let's start at the beginning with
some maps
i always find it helpful to look at maps
as a way of illustrating what's been
going on i'm sorry it's hard for you
to see up there and turn your back but
the map on the left hand side the first
map
represents palestine as it was under the
british mandate
which uh covers the whole of what is now
uh the modern israel and the occupied
territories
the second map is what the un
proposed as the partition plan lines
that would form the israeli and the
proposed arab state or jewish and arab
state as they called them
in those days and the white bit it
was proposed for the state of israel and
the yellow bit or brown whichever you
like to call it
was proposed to be the arab state
the third map gives you an idea of what
actually happened
after the british withdrew and after the
1948
war of independence and the one before
would have given israel i think about 54
55 percent of
of the land and and the arabs about 45
after the 1948 war of independence that
gave roughly 78
of the land to the israelis and 22
to the palestinians the palestinians in
the west bank you can see on the right
hand side of the two yellow bits
the left hand side is the gaza strip and
the idea would be in the event of an
arab state that you'd have some kind of
road or
railway or something that would connect
the two so that palestinians could get
from one
one part of the territory to the other
and the final map on the right hand side
is roughly where we are today in terms
of the yellow bits or
where the palestinians live and the
white bits
are where the um israelis live
this is a map of the west bank and the
west bank
is where the settlements we're talking
about tonight
are they you can see jerusalem sort of
quite low
low down on the map so to the left of
these yellow bits is the state of it is
is israel and the rest of what you're
seeing
is is the west bank uh the
brown bits on the west bank
where israelis uh have control
and uh the blue bits are the settlements
the brown lines
are the roads which connect them all up
and the white so
white bit white is a sort of strange
color but it's a creamy color are the
bits where the palestinians live and as
you can see
because of these roads and so forth
they're sort of broken up into lots of
little areas where they live this is
another way of
of showing you the map it's what some
people describe as a
an archipelago or a succession of of
little bits
which don't create the possibility or
the easy possibility
of what some people would describe as a
contiguous
palestinian state just as importantly
if if i go back a map you can see that
the whole brown bit on the right
is what connects up to the border with
jordan
with the river jordan and that is all
under
israeli control so the if that bit
remains so and the palestinians didn't
have that
the palestinians wouldn't have a an
independent border
so that gives you i think an idea of
where we are today
how people live today now over the last
25 years or so
there's been a peace process in progress
as you know
led by successive united states
administrations
the process has been attempting to
secure a peace agreement between
israeli and palestinian leaders leading
to a creation of a palestinian state
and that palestinian state as i said
would be the gaza strip
and that whole west bank area
but during the period of the peace
process successive israeli governments
have settled about 550 to 600 000 dani
will tell us the exact amount israeli
citizens
on palestinian land that's in the west
bank and east jerusalem
land that the international community
have traditionally accepted
as the basis for a future palestinian
state
this is what begs the the serious
questions if the state of israel
is genuinely pursuing peace
why is it intent on settling its
citizens on land that it would have to
return
why is it spending tens of millions of
dollars every year
on building projects of housing and
infrastructure roads and so forth
that would be unrecoverable cynics would
say that this is because israel is not
interested in making peace
it has no genuine intention of creating
a palestinian state
but instead intends to take over the
whole of the west bank
creating an israel from the river jordan
all the way over to the mediterranean
sea
and given the nature of public debate in
the current election campaign in israel
this is not entirely far-fetched there
are plenty of members
of the governing coalition who've
publicly stated their opposition to a
palestinian state
let alone one that would be based as the
international community desires on the
pre-1967 borders
leading israeli politicians have in the
last week advocated even the annexation
of large tracts of the west bank to
secure them as
permanent israeli territory once and for
all and this may well in fact
end up being a policy of the next
israeli government
so settlement building is continuing a
pace not just within the existing
settlements new
outposts are being established every
year in the west bank
and despite international criticism even
from israel's closest ally the united
states
the process continues often funded by
donations from the united states
supported by tax breaks for u.s citizens
who make these kinds of donations so
given the rate of this
settlement development it's hard to find
any international political figure
who genuinely believes in the israeli
government's intent to seek peace with
the palestinians
based on the 1967 borders maybe with
some land swaps
with a capital in east jerusalem and the
rhetoric of the current israeli
election campaign combined with these
maps
uh tell a story and i think you'd have
to be peculiarly credulous individual
to believe a different story which
brings me
to my second point israel's waning
support in the international community
in november mahmoud abbas the
palestinian president
apparently frustrated with the lack of
any progress with the peace process
because as he puts it of israel's
continued settlement policies
went to the general assembly of the
united nations in order to try and
secure observer status
for a palestinian state
now in the vote some 138 countries of
the world voted in favor
41 abstained and only eight countries
of the 187 in the voting process
apart from israel voted against
these countries were the marshall
islands
palau nauru and micronesia
four tiny island states in the middle of
the pacific ocean
panama the czech republic canada
and the united states this is what is
left
of the international support for the
state of israel when it really needs it
it's hard to think of a more isolated
country in the world
apart from iran and north korea
and for israel to be able to rely on the
support
of rely neither on the support of the uk
france or germany or even the
netherlands on this issue
is a rather dismal sign so when
netanyahu announced the building of
further settlements as a punishment for
the palestinians
going to the un for observer status
condemnation instantly appeared from
none other than the u.s canadian and
czech diplomats
who felt that their support in the un
vote had been betrayed
so where does this leave israel well if
it continues its settlement policies and
refuses to accept the international
parameters
of the peaceful two-state solution then
i believe the process of israel's
de-legitimization
moral political legal the thing it fears
the most will continue to develop a pace
what are the alternatives well there's a
plausible alternative to a two-state
solution
and it's a one-state solution where
everyone jews and palestinians
live together and are equal citizens in
the same country
but this leads to the jews being in a
minority an outcome unlikely to be
plausible to jewish israelis and
advocates of a jewish state
some israelis are now advocating a
one-state solution
but they would rather like to leave gaza
behind so they can ensure the jewish
majority which is
not likely to appeal to the outside
world or obviously the palestinians
so if it's not a two-state solution or a
one-state solution
what do we call what's left the current
status quo
if israel does not allow any prospect of
statehood freedom
genuine self-governance for the
palestinians and with israeli citizens
having markedly different rights and
standards of living
to their palestinian counterparts and
with israel running out of friends on
the international stage
the situation i'm afraid will inevitably
lead to accusations from some countries
in the world
that this situation is one of apartheid
and that means that those countries will
call for israel's increasing isolation
in time it will mean no more world cups
no more olympics
and my final point should be just as
worrying for israel
there are now so many settlers in east
jerusalem in the west bank that even
if an israeli government wanted to make
peace and withdraw hundreds of thousands
of settlers back to israel
it looks almost impossible to do every
year more and more settlers are becoming
army officers
policemen judges politicians the very
people who will if the time comes
have to supervise orchestrate and
legitimize the withdrawal of settlers
from their home
and their lands the more settlers there
are
the harder it will be to do and it'll be
harder for an israeli government to be
elected
who advocates a withdrawal turkeys do
not vote for christmas
as they say in britain so that's my
conclusion
it looks straightforward i think it's
pretty obvious when you look at the maps
that the two-state solution is
disappearing the one-state solution is
hardly going to be popular
in israel and the support for israel is
going downwards
not upwards i think in the long term
this leads
tragically that israel is heading
towards its own
destruction and that's why i support
this motion
thank you very much
um thank you very much william i should
have
explained that the reason i was tapping
at my glasses i'm under
strict instruction there's one thing i
have to do tonight
um apart from cleaning my teeth when i
go to bed is and that's um
to limit uh excellent speakers to 12
minutes and
they get a two minute warning after 10
minutes so that's the gentle
tap on the glass and then i get more
vigorous after 12 minutes
anyway our next speaker is danny dyan
he's chairman of the yeshua council
of jewish communities in judea and
samaria previously he served on the
steering committee that reconstituted
the yeshua council after its failure to
prevent the 2005
gaza disengagement and during his tenure
as
chairman appropriately enough a greater
focus
is being placed on what
in hebrews called hasbera public
diplomacy
both in israel and overseas which is why
happily
danny is here danny thank you very much
first of all i would like to apologize
for my less than perfect english with
the heavy argentinian accent when i came
to heathrow yesterday the guy at the
immigration
told me what's the purpose of my visit
pleasure or business
i told him to give a lecture so he told
me you can go in
but you have to promise you won't talk
about the falklands
i suspect i am going to
speak about a much more inflammatory
issue than the falklands
um i beg you to put aside all the
stereotypes you may have
and all the demonization you have been
exposed to
in the media and all the prejudices
and think everything doubt everything i
could choose the easy way
to prove that the motion
is wrong the easy way is
that should it be right that israel is
destroying it say
itself with its settlements policy i
would expect an
over overwhelming support for
settlements in arab countries
but we don't of course but that's that
is too easy
look if it were right
you can justify emotion like that on two
grounds
on the moral ground you could suggest
that israel
is eroding its moral standing
and i hear that argument with its
settlement policy
or on strategic grounds israel is making
itself
more more vulnerable with its
settlements policy
but the fact is that neither of those
two arguments
is true i would like to start with the
moral one because in my opinion
is the more important
in and that in which more disinformation
and defamation is being spread
the israeli-palestinian conflict the
jewish palestinian conflict call it
whatever way you like
is a peculiar one
you cannot compare it for instance with
the israeli egyptian
dispute the israeli-palestinian conflict
is a conflict
like not no other one in the world
in the sense that there are two ethnic
groups
jews and palestinians that have
their beliefs their historical
narratives
and i dare to say even if i'm criticized
by some of my colleagues
that both are sincere i'm not saying
they're
i i don't want to judge if they are
right or wrong
both are sincere i feel
that zionism is the national liberation
movement of the jewish people
i am deeply touched by hebron
in judea and by suffering in galilee
in the preyna in the first one in the
post-67
israel the first one in the pre-67
israel ii
and mahmoud abbas is deeply touched by
both
by hebron advisor he too is deeply
touched by both
i see zionism as the national liberation
movement of the jewish people
and they see it sincerely
as the 19th century colonialist and evil
israel not the settlements because they
consider themselves the natives
and us the africanus that came to usurp
that their land
now how do you resolve such a dispute
there is no other dispute like that in
the world
you could suggest that partition the
so-called two states is the just
solution
maybe but what happens
when one side accepts partition and we
saw the maps
that the partition proposed in 1947
with improbable borders for the jewish
state and
without jerusalem we and we we i i
wasn't born
that that time but we the jews went out
to the squares of tel aviv and jerusalem
and
to dance to dance horror in the squares
and they attacked us dead that very same
night
not in order to get a better partition
in order to annihilate us
until 1967 from 1947 to 1967
the arabs the palestinians had the
opportunity to sign a peace treaty with
israel
along the green line but instead
in 1964 they established the plo the
palestine liberation organization
to liberate tel aviv not to liberate
hebron
and then they attacked in order again to
annihilate israel
now i want you to listen very
attentively
to what i'm going to say now because in
my
subjective opinion it's sheer
logic and ethics you cannot
go to square one after such an act
when you deny when you reject partition
and attack the other side in order to
take it
all by force you lost the moral ground
to
demand partition by the way
it was done again in the year two
thousand
when our prime minister heyud barak
proposed partition in camp david to
yahshua rafat with president
bill clinton and kim david
yasser arafat as the leader of the
palestinians not only rejected it
but three months later he launched the
most vicious
terrorist attack of the modern era the
so-called second intifada
so from a moral ground we came back
to our land rightfully
we were ready
to relinquish the most sacred parts the
most important parts of our patrimony
of our national patrimony but
going but the palestinians rejected it
they could have a state
they could part divide the land they
decided that the rule of the game is by
force
and that we prevailed using the rules of
the game
they decided upon from a moral point of
view
our presence in judea and samaria and
the so-called west bank
erroneously called west bank is morally
impeccable
yes in a 100 year war we made mistakes
and we made injustices yes of course you
cannot
make it you cannot in a 100 year
so bloody conflict
not make any injustice we did our share
of injustices
but in the moral balance between jews
and palestinians
we go we have the upper hand by far
and we have a inalienable right
to be and to live in judea and samaria
now you could say okay it is just
you have any you have a moral
justification to
live and to build houses and gardens
and wineries in judea and samaria but it
is not wise
it's a stupid policy that will bring
even if you you will die you will commit
suicide
with justice but no the contrary is the
truth
i heard mr zigart
talking about the fair the the
in what will happen if the two-state
solution
does not crystallize
and this is the second preconception
i beg you to free yourself off
the two-state solution the two-states
formula
does not solve the conflict in the
middle east
on the contrary it will aggravate it
i live in a small community in western
samaria named maleshomron
from my home in malaysia omron
every morning i look at tel aviv
as if it were in the palm of my hands
the azrieli towers i see that the
azrieli towers the icon the new icon of
tel aviv
are in its place in their place
and then i'd go to work knowing that
everything is okay in tel aviv
the thought that
if instead of my wife my daughter and
myself
in malaysia in that very same window
an independent palestinian state will be
looking and yearning for jaffa
looking and yearning for the places that
they consider
their national patrimony from high above
because in the map you also you don't
see the the topography
by the way much closer
than the distance from heathrow to
london
much higher than hydro of course to
london
completely dominating the the landscape
the thought that that
will bring the palestinians
to accept partition as a feta complete
it will not tempt them to launch a new
aggression to wipe out israel from the
map
is in the best case naive
in the worst case i prefer not to
characterize it
without juden samaria without the high
hills of judea and samaria
an uninterrupted islamic
fundamentalist territory
that starts in kabul afghanistan
and ends in tel aviv israel
without any natural barrier exists
only a a offense
will will separate
tel aviv from the ter from the islamic
dominated territory that ends in kabul
afghanistan
that is suicide that is
suicide now
we did that experiment why should we
guess
we did that experiment in the summer in
the infamous summer of 2005.
i think it was albert einstein that once
said that
if you do the same experiment twice and
expect
different results then you are no
scientist maybe he used the
a more offending word offensive world
the experiment was the withdrawal from
gaza
we evacuated every single jew from there
civilian or military
a de facto independent palestinian state
was established
in gaza and we all know the consequence
the consequences that every single penny
every single cent every single euro and
dollar and pound that was
contributed to the newly formed
de facto independent state palestinian
state in gaza
was used to amass armaments against
israel
to form a new launching pad for an
aggression against israel
and not for highways not for schools not
for hospitals not for universities
the difference and this is my summing
my concluding remark the difference is
that israel can survive
an iranian proxy state in gaza
because the surround because the limit
the
the surrounding areas are not very
densely
populated of course
it's not a good situation but because we
can't somehow cope with it
the same thing in judea and samaria and
it will be inevitably the same thing
inevitably
by coup d'etat by gun or by ballot the
hamas will take control of the
new palestinian state will endanger
the very physical existence of the
status israel
therefore the settlements do not
endanger israel
israel's existence but guarantee it
thank you
thank you very much danny uh
next speaker is daniel levy
levy i do beg his pardon i was i was so
impressed with my pronunciation of
hasbera
just before with um danny diane that i
decided to give you the full
hebraic pronunciation daniel levy he's
the director of the
middle east and north africa program at
the european council on foreign
relations he's also
the senior fellow at the new america
foundation uh he's a member of the board
of the new israel fund as well as
a former advisor in the israeli prime
minister's office and
a member of the israeli team
that was at one point negotiating with
the palestinians
daniel thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much tim and i'd like to
thank the organizers of intelligence
squared and
everyone here for joining us tonight
monty python's meaning of life
a film it contains a scene there's an
obese chap
really a caricature of obesity
mr creosote he walks into a restaurant
apparently it's his
regular local he orders everything on
the menu
and a jeroboam of champagne after all
this
the waiter offers him just one wafer
thin
mint to round off the meal he
momentarily hesitates
then mr creosolt consumes said mint
he promptly explodes for me
that is the danger that settlement
overreach
poses to israel eventually it will
explode
in our faces just one more waffer thin
outpost just a little e1
i will now devote my remaining remarks
to those of you not familiar with monty
python's the meaning of life
look there is a certain powerful logic
to the idea
that israel as we know it simply
cannot coexist with the relentless
continuation
and expansion of settlements in contra
mention of international law
let's look at it like this imagine
there's a triangle
made up of three sides of the basic
choices that israel faces
one is a state with a jewish character
drawn amongst other things from a clear
majority of its citizenry
being jewish the second outline
is in israel that is democrat
recognizably democratic
observing democratic norms respecting
democratic rights
adhering to the international
conventions it signed
investing that democracy with meaning
and the third is an israel that has all
the territory
the territory of the biblical home if
you like the territory now under its
control the territory
across which settlements are spread as
those previous maps showed
but in fact israel can only have two
sides of this triangle
it can be democratic and jewish in
character
but not have all the territory or it can
have all the territory
and choose to give up either its
democratic character
or its jewish character for with the
territory
comes its inhabitants and they can
either be accorded
democratic rights or denied those rights
it's a relatively simple equation i
prefer to say it's irrefutable and send
us all home early
but let's dig a little deeper there are
those who accept this basic premise who
accept yes two states
i'm not sure we'll hear that position
tonight but you hear it often
but they then say chill out about
settlements the chill-out camp
they're just not a big deal you
exaggerate their significance they can
always be removed there are bigger
problems
if you want to do two states what about
the historical narratives what about
rejectionism on both sides security
really the settlements
i would argue the opposite if you're
arguing from a two-state
perspective the single most
prohibitive factor to achieving a
two-state outcome
i would say is the settlement enterprise
the single biggest
practical on the ground driving force
toward the indivisibility of this land
is the settlements even if the built up
area of settlements
takes up only a small area the truth is
it's about one percent of the west bank
but the area under settlement
jurisdiction
the municipal and regional settlement
councils control the zoning and planning
that's 42.8 percent of the west bank
settlements help define palestinian
access or actually lack of access
to land to resources
even to quarries and palestinian freedom
of movement
and this picture becomes even more stark
if one factors in
patterns of set patterns of settlement
and land expropriation
in palestinian east jerusalem making the
viability of a future palestinian state
all the more impossible and settlements
define a cognitive map in people's minds
encouraging the world and the
palestinians
to give up on a two-state outcome or at
least consider it
a vanishing prospect
there is a variation on the chill-out
crowd
which is this that the two-state model
is okay
with settlements because it can
accommodate any amount of settlement
growth
the palestinians can swallow any deal
their
territory can shrink to whatever
enfeebled island it is willing to be
offered
whatever infringement on their resources
and sovereignty
let's not delude ourselves the
palestinian leadership accepted
the idea of a mini state on 22
of the land not the 43 percent of the
partition plan
if you want to go along with the idea of
some element of victor's justice
and rejectionists remorse
i don't think there's much room for
further retreat
there is a point at which the aspiration
for palestinian statehood
under such limited circumstances
becomes less attractive attractive to
palestinians
and the appeal of a one-state democracy
carries the day
this is true already for many
palestinians
and settlements bring that day closer
for many more thanks very much tim
what if no no i'm finished i'm going to
use my 25 minutes now
thanks a lot
but you could say what if you look
beyond the traditional two-state
paradigm is that the only solution you
can come up with
not one where there's no israel but one
maybe there's a confederation maybe
something like belgium maybe something
involving jordan
i think it's clear that settlement
policy reduced the
reduces the prospects of all these
alternatives
why would a palestine that's part of a
confederation or part of something to do
with jordan
be any more willing to base itself on
atomized islands of land without
resources
surrounded and with security
arrangements dictated only by one side
you know there is a reason that two
former israeli prime ministers
and israel's i guess cultural icon amos
oz
have have spoken of an approaching
reality
of south african style of python but i
as i said i'm not sure these are going
to be the main arguments we're going to
hear tonight
so let's not make it easy on ourselves
let's step out of this comfortable
paradigm
what if i am getting it all wrong what
if like the toy store
settlements are us there's no difference
between pre-67 and post-67
one side of the green line and another
side of the green line
but far from destroying israel
settlement policy simply encapsulates
the very essence of what israel is after
all ra matavir tel aviv university
is built on the ruins of the palestinian
village of sheikh munus
and there's the list can go on i can
certainly understand
that from a palestinian's experience
such distinctions might well appear to
be rather arbitrary
and not very relevant green line not
green line
and a palestinian might have rather less
interest in whether
israel is destroying itself or not as
compared to say
whether palestinian rights and freedoms
are able to be exercised
but we don't have palestinian speakers
with us here today i can't be an
advocate for palestinians william khan
mrs diane and glick may enjoy settling
palestinian land but i don't know if
that makes them advocates
for the palestinians
i hope a future debate will invite
palestinians
but and there is of course such a
perspective held in the israeli zionist
discourse that israel
equals settlements which could render
our debate meaningless
and i admit that to some such a
definition of israel may sound more
coherent more compelling
even more honest
but there's a problem here because that
is not how israel has defined itself
israel calls itself a democracy a jewish
and
democratic state it enshrined these
principles
in its declaration of independence it is
a signatory to international charters
that enshrines these principles
the israel that has embedded itself in
the community of nations
and in the hearts and minds of jews and
others across the world
is the democratic israel that carries
the legitimacy
that is the israel that is also on the
67 lines
been recognized by the plo itself so
unless and until
israel redefines itself let's say we
call it the jewish empire of greater
israel
until then that is the standard
against which one has to measure whether
israel is destroying itself
with settlements or not
there is a democratic recession going on
in israel
i would argue that the settlements drive
that democratic recession
it's impossible to sustain a democracy
on one side of a green line if you're
managing a norton democracy on the other
there could be an opening maybe this can
just be a bi-national democracy
it's the 21st century percentages of
jews percentages of non-jews really
this is what we have to bother ourselves
with but again
would that be called israel does it not
answer the definition
of this debate
i want to finally
say the following and i want to be
careful
not to turn the oive dial up too high
but i think one can argue that
settlement policy is a driving factor in
israel endangering itself
not just in the sense of defining what
israel is
but also in a very real physical sense
that settlements constitute a high risk
strategy
for the security and well-being of
israelis
and israel that settlements are the
greatest barrier
between israel and pragmatic policies
between israel and realistic policies
especially in the reality we face today
let's just look at it
a new arab reality in which democratic
enfranchisement
has come to the fore a reality in which
technological gaps
including israel's qualitative military
edge
are narrowing over time a reality in
which israel is
so dependent on the us sorry and the
pacific islands states
in which palestinian non-violent civil
disobedience
gathers steam but also in which armed
uprisings against depression
have received regional and international
support in syria libya and elsewhere
and in which israel is losing its
legitimacy and experiencing a brain
drain at home
in that reality are settlements not
the greatest manifestation of overreach
the reason why we have an israel without
borders
are settlements the way forward do they
contribute to israeli security
or do they threaten to push israel over
the edge
and is this our only future is it
really a viable future to live by the
sword
in perpetuity
i'll close by saying this i can see them
there are some speech bubbles coming out
of some people's heads
naive naive naive the man's a defeatist
if we ended the settlements with the
arabs really except us
they opposed us before 67 after 67
with them to live in peace
to me that's the defeatism to believe
that there is no better future
are the palestinians uniquely intolerant
uniquely impossible to make peace with
are we uniquely destined to be enemies
forever i'd argue that that view is a
historical
is a misreading of reality and it's a
more than a little bit prejudiced
unique permanent unreasonableness does
not apply to palestinians or muslims
it does not apply to jews or israelis
if we remove the casa's belly the
burning humiliation of today and
tomorrow
will everything still be dictated by the
humiliations of yesterday
and history both peoples can be
forward-looking
and to support this motion is to send a
message
that settlements are taking us to a
point of no return
not a smart strategy for israel's future
thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much daniel um caroline
glick is our
final speaker she's a senior
contributing editor at the jerusalem
post
newspaper she's director of the israel
security project at the david horowitz
freedom center and she's the senior
adjunct fellow for middle eastern
affairs at the center for security
policy
she's the author of one book shackled
warrior
israel and the global jihad she was also
saying before we came in
to this room this evening that she's
taking a very
precious day off writing her next book
which is due at the publishers in march
so
i hope you will give her a sympathetic
audience tonight
caroline thank you very much thank you
thanks it's really a pleasure to be here
in london i think the last time i was
here was in 95 and i think that daniel
might have been my soldier then i can't
remember
but i i
find i find the whole resolution rather
curious
i did just fly in here from israel where
i live with
my children and i i think that i'm
pretty pro-israel
but this resolution essentially tells me
that in order to be pro-israel
i have to support the establishment of a
jew free state
for the palestinians
i have to say that i support the
establishment of a state that is going
to be
that must be ethnically cleansed of all
jews before
the people who are supposed to have that
state will agree to independence
i find that crazy
the presence of jews in judea and
samaria
the west bank of the jordan river has
nothing to do with prospects for peace
or
lack of prospects for peace israel has
two peace agreements with
two neighboring arab states it's that
have been respected
the one with egypt for nearly 30 years
one with jordan since
uh it was signed in 1994. um
and we signed six agreements with the
palestinians with the plo all six of
which they have been in material breach
of uh since the very beginning
but none of those agreements that we
signed with the plo nor the agreements
that we signed with the jordanians or
the egyptians war impacted one iota by
the presence of jewish communities
beyond israel's 1949 armistice lines
not one of them was contingent on the
absence of those communities
and nobody made that a condition for
negotiating with the jewish state
or for recognizing it
um
so if you think that
throwing 500 000 jews 350
000 jews 650 000 jews 720 000 jews out
of their homes
and their communities is the magic
bullet
through which we are going to achieve
peace with the palestinian arabs
um you're living in fantasyland this has
not been the case in the past
it has not been the case with our arab
neighbors it has not been the case with
our palestinian neighbors
and there is no reason to to accept the
view
that it is the case today the other
argument
that we've heard today is that if jews
keep living and building in jewish
in in judea and samaria we're going to
end up with a one-state solution in
which jews
are a minority so
let's think about this for a second
you're saying that
by keeping jews in judea and samaria and
in jerusalem
that somehow or another the palestinians
are going to
inc and the israeli arabs within the
1949's armistice lines
are somehow going to magically bridge
the 3 million person gap between the 6.1
million jews
and the 3 million arabs
inside of 1949 armistice lines israel
and judea and samaria you don't know how
to count
you don't know how to count were israel
to absorb judah and samaria tomorrow and
offer citizenship
to all of its arab residents israel
would still have a two-thirds jewish
majority
so the very notion that there is a
demographic time bomb on israel's hands
is simply untrue
the central bureau of statistics of
israel came out yesterday with its
latest data
they found that there is convergence
between
jewish birth rates and arab birth rates
and the jewish birth rates are trending
upwards and have been since 1995 and the
era of birth rates are trending
downwards and have since 2000. in fact
this is not just among the palestinians
or among the israeli arabs this is
throughout the
arab world there is a collapse in the
muslim world
infertility rights and there is a
massive increase in jewish fertility
rights israel has three children per
woman
among jews and it has 3.5
children per woman among muslims inside
a pre-1949 armistice lines israel
and 3.2 children per woman in judea and
samaria among
the arab population in the area so that
the whole
trend of the demographic model is
completely
the opposite of what all of these uh
experts on israel's demographic
dire circumstances would have us all
believe
it's simply a matter of not counting
properly
now the truth of the matter is none of
this is important
because the whole issue of whether or
not the settlements in judea and samaria
are somehow or another going to destroy
israel or not is not about demography
and it's not about peace it's about
civil rights it's about jewish civil
rights what they are saying essentially
is that jews should not be allowed to
live there just because they're jews
now why should jews be allowed to live
in london
live in germany live in san francisco
but not be allowed to live in judea
why and in jerusalem where does this
come from
they want to talk so much about
palestinian rights let's talk about
jewish rights for a second you're saying
that you so support a palestinian state
that is going to be inherently bigoted
and that jews aren't allowed to even
live there that they have to all be
ethnically cleansed
first before these people can even deign
to accept sovereignty
what kind of state do you want to
establish what kind of nonsense is this
is a racket
this is a racket jews don't have civil
rights we're not allowed to live
wherever we have property rights to
build
just because we're jewish and this is a
moral argument
this is a reasonable argument this is
establishing what
exactly a state based upon ethnic purity
this is where we've come to
in 2013 in the western world where are
the liberal values that are being
advanced by this cause of a jew free
palestine somebody can explain this one
to me because i don't understand it
i don't understand it i don't understand
i went to columbia i went to harvard
i just can't get it and let me just say
one more thing about that
i can talk from now i've heard illegal
palestinian land all of this i'm not
going to have a discussion here about
sovereignty i talk about that in my book
it's out it's going to be coming out
hopefully at the end of the year random
house you can all look for it and buy
multiple copies
but if we want to we can talk about
israel's national rights and our legal
rights to these areas
they are very strong and in fact they're
incontrovertible in under international
law
but we're talking about civil rights
we're talking about civil rights
and it's not simply that it's morally
repugnant to tell jews that we're not
allowed to live anywhere we want to
and buy property anywhere that will be
sold it
it's also true that this is a failed
proposition it's been tried twice and
it's failed twice
the british tried it you tried it in
1939
and in 1940 with the white paper and the
subsequent acts of parliament that
denied jews the right to buy land
in the vast majority of the palestinian
mandate that the british government was
legally bound by the mandate of the
league of nations to allow close jewish
settlement of throughout
you abrogated that right in material
breach
of the mandate of the league of nations
in 1939 and 1940 and how did that work
out
it was done at the time in may 1939 in
order to appease the palestinian arabs
who at that point were allied with the
nazis
and were conducting a terrorist war not
only against the jews of the palestine
mandate but against the british
mandatory authorities and in an attempt
to appease hajime
hussaini who by that time was in baghdad
stirring up an
uh pro-nazi uh coup d'etat that took
place in 1941
the british said that the jews have no
national rights and we actually didn't
mean that we supported the establishment
of a jewish state when we said we did in
1917 in the balfour declaration whoops
and you know what happened you know what
happened
there was a pro-nazi coup in iraq and
britain
that was pinned down in libya had to go
and invade iraq in order to take it down
and then they had to invade iran because
in iran you had preachers in the mosque
saying hey hitler is the second coming
of muhammad
and that's what they did and this is
what they got for appeasement
they got king farouk in egypt supporting
the nazis they got the iraqis supporting
the nazis they got a nazi party in syria
it didn't work and by the way they did
it at the time
that what they abrogated jewish civil
rights in the middle of the holocaust
morally repugnant and strategically
ridiculous
it didn't work we tried it again as
danny said in 2005 and what did we get 8
000 jews thrown out of their homes 24
communities in gaza raised to the ground
and transferred to the palestinians
what did we get we got hamas in charge
it wasn't just an abrogation of jewish
civil rights
it ended up becoming an abrogation of
palestinian civil rights just ask the
christians in gaza
just last month they went to bethlehem
for the christ for the christmas
celebrations and they came to israel and
they said don't make us go home can we
please have asylum here
can we save us pretty soon
just weeks from now there's not going to
be any more ancient christian community
in gaza
but whose civil rights are being
impacted here
not just ours not just the jews but the
arabs as well
the women in gaza who are now being
increasingly intimidated so you have to
run around
wearing a big hat over your head or how
about those summer camps that are being
firebombed by hamas because they have
girls and boys together
whose civil rights are advanced by the
expropriation illegally
of land from jews in the transfer of the
palestinians
nobody nobody
i tell you what this is what we're
talking about here you want to know what
we're really talking about here when we
talk about throwing all these jews off
the lands that we bought that belong to
us
we are talking about trying to find
common ground with terrorist
organizations
that are mandated to enact a genocide of
the jewish people just read the hamas
covenant just see what they say they
call not for
only the annihilation the obliteration
in their words of the jewish state
but they call for the genocide of world
jewry
and to try to find common ground with
these murderers or with holocaust
deniers like plo chief mahmoud abbas
we have people like danny levy and mr
seahart saying what
oh what we can agree that there's a
subset of jews that we also dislike
right let's call them the settlers and
say that they're destroying all
prospects for peace not hamas
not fatah that are throwing missiles at
the homes of
now 3.5 million jews are in their range
from gaza
no no no no no it's because jews are
have the temerity to build on land that
they own
that's the problem we can sit down and
talk to hamas because
we like them hate jews now we don't hate
all jews but a subset and we're going to
blame
everything all the pathologies of the
arab world all the pathologies the
palestinians
on them it's their fault they're going
to block peace not true
again to return to the beginning at the
end of my remarks israel has
two peace treaties one with jordan one
with egypt that are just fine thank you
very much for asking
and they were signed sealed and
delivered and maintained
while israel was expanding the jewish
presence in judea and sumerian gaza
we signed six agreements with the plo
again none of which they've maintained
or adhered to but they were all signed
while we were building in judean samaria
how is it that suddenly
this is the obstacle to peace because
you can now find common ground when you
all want to
delegitimize israel oh we can all agree
that we hate these specific jews and
they should all be thrown out of their
houses
this is a moral atrocity it is morally
reprehensible
it is strategically idiotic
and this resolution should
be opposed by all of you unanimously
thank you very much
[Music]
thank you very much caroline and uh
thank you
to all of you for listening to the
speakers in uh
silence and for the most part and uh
except when you laughed when you were
supposed to
and and also i got a sense that you were
all concentrating as i was concentrating
very very closely on what they had to
say
um it's my uh task
now before i throw
uh this open to the floor to tell you
what the result of the
pre-debate poll was i'm told that
there's always a lot of don't knows
um in these debates i said i was rather
skeptical that in this debate there were
going to be a lot of don't knows but
there were a fair number anyway the
number
this was before the speakers began
talking
was uh 343 for the motion
97 against 192
don't know so uh in order to
try and further uh exploration of the
issues i
we're gonna have a question and answer
session um
for those of you who've seen me do this
sort of gig before you'll
know that the tired joke that's about to
roll over the horizon and i apologize
but
especially when it comes to discussing
israel it tends to be
an answer and answer session rather than
a question and answer session
just for the sake of brevity and sanity
and to allow
as many people as possible to get
their questions in please try
and restrain yourself and have a
question
at least a question mark at the end
upwards intonation helps um if you put
up your hands i will try and get around
as many as possible
please wait for the microphone and what
we'll do is we'll take take them
in uh clumps of two or three and then
ask the panel for their thoughts so
first of all there's a there's a very
well illuminated hand actually behind
you
um the lady in the glasses
thank you very much for the
presentations
i think that every site has got a valid
points
what bothers me is i am not for the
settlements
i feel that i don't understand
with modern central statistics
there are more arabs living in the
galilee than jews
the negev is very sparsely populated why
don't the settlers
live there and strengthen israel
and from the moral point of view
i am a bit baffled that israel wants
the un to do justice
but there seems to be one moral law for
israel
and one for other people because when it
doesn't
suit israel it does other things
so it's a bit of a pity and i think
thank you where's the other microphone
on oh excellent there it is
thank you speak can i ask for
clarification
the term is always used that the
israelis are expropriating land
in the west bank for settlements the
last speaker spoke about land
that was owned by the settlers that the
settlers had bought
i think that's quite an important point
and i'd be grateful for clarification
of whether the land is always purchased
from the palestinians
as opposed to expropriated excellent um
let's see if the
microphone is now working jews live in
england
and they abide by english laws
jews living in the occupied territories
abide by which law
okay well i'll i'll repeat the questions
um
so um let me i'll i'll ask
sort of one of you from from both sides
you can decide among yourselves the
the the questions were um
why don't settlers go to the
inside the green lines uh and strengthen
israel uh the the state of israel within
the uh
green lines
what is it with this land that's been
bought by the settlers appropriated by
the settlers what's the status
of settlement land and
why don't jews in
the settlements abide by israeli law
what law no no no that's not the
question the question is
what law should they abide by that was
the
question if i'm doing you justice thank
you i'll um
i'll go and get my coat and i'll um
no no it's fine he's never forgiven me
for mispronouncing his surname
um caroline and danny those are quite
the factual
questions so they have three very short
factual answers the first one regarding
the
galilee and the negev is that we do
second and third generation
so-called settlers from judea and
samaria now establish communities both
in the negev and
in the galilee with our support and our
encouragement
so you know i i uh for a long time have
got to the conclusion that the persons
that take upon themselves zionist causes
and uh and what in hebrew we call it
yashvut
to to to populate the distant
areas of the country they do it
everywhere and those that prefer
the easy life in tel aviv
do not not don't from the galilee are
not in the negative and not in judea and
samaria the second factual question
from above i think was about the status
of the land
uh well someone i think
i think it was daniel that recalled us
of the fact that tel aviv university
in ramadave is an under built on the
ruins of an
arab village of muniz so
please rest rest assured that no
settlement is on the ruins of of any
arab
village more than that no arab
was evacuated from his home in order to
build a settlement
uh well
that is a fact you can laugh as long as
you can
i know now daniel will say hebron and
hebron
is the exception that proves the rule
uh uh um you can laugh as long as you
know as
but i i challenge you to show me one
case
in which an arab a palestinian was
evicted from his home in judea and
samaria in order
in order to establish there in order to
establish there will be a chance for
people to intervene for the floor again
but danny danny move on to the
because we want to get other questions
this is a fact
movie move on to the last question which
is
and moreover since 1979
the ruling by the supreme court of
justice of israel
even no expropriation with monetary
compensation is allowed
on on in non-inhabited land
in order to establish a settlement
now if you do not accept the facts then
it's very difficult to to to make an
intelligent uh
an intelligent discussion here the third
one was which law we abide of course we
have by the law of israel
thank you very much is it going to be
yeah yeah
no really
i don't think supporting this motion is
about poking israel in the eye
or how terrible israel is or even about
demonizing settlers i'm going to
interrupt you because it sounds almost
like a
summing up speech can you answer those
three specific questions
you can have your own arguments but you
can't have your own facts
and and the entire basis
i mean but but but literally we could we
could open
the equivalent of a swear box on the
exit
from this hall and i just think from the
combined people in this audience we
could collect a hundred
factually accurate rebuttals
of what we've heard today and sadly tens
of examples
of palestinian private land and
palestinian dispossession but
you know i've said i've said you know
i have said from the beginning we've
i've said from the beginning
no one on this panel is a palestinian
hey
could you give one you know you know the
danny a liar i would like him to give
one example of a lie
i think it's fair okay but we'll we'll
try and take it in turns
to speak
there is there is not there is not
one palestinian on this panel
there's also no one on this panel who
was born in israel
sorry
so no one on this
there are three people on this panel who
have veiled themselves of the
opportunity that the law of return
provides to every jew around the world
to move to israel
i really hope that in the future there
will be a debate
where a palestinian a variety of
palestinian perspectives
can be heard but i'm not the person to
provide a palestinian perspective i can
correct
some of your mistakes i can explain that
and then you know this well that when
negotiations have been serious
the uh the palestinians have been
willing
to look at land swaps to look at land
i just answered the questions
you are running away to to to a
completely different topic
blaming me or not telling the truth
without is
is there expropriation okay let me
no but it's just there's so much factual
inaccuracy that has been
shared in the name of one arab that was
evicted from his home and today
the name of one arab i don't carry
around though i don't care
i don't carry around danny we i i just
want to
to ask uh let me let me just put one
question to you uh daniel the the one
about
uh which law is being uh
respected here uh it's a very
interesting question
it's a very interesting question because
the point put by danny the only way
is israeli law which is being respected
well it's not of course because israeli
law has not been extended to the
occupied territories
because the occupied territories have
not been annexed to israel
what you have is that jerusalem has been
annexed to israel
something not recognized anywhere else
in the world
the west bank is administered
de facto as an occupied territory by
israel israel
has not taken upon itself that de jure
but in practice what you have is a
hodgepodge
of legislations there where the israeli
military is sometimes making up the
rules
sometimes it's drawn from jordanian law
sometimes ottoman law
sometimes israeli law and almost always
whatever most
suits israel and sadly increasingly the
case of the settlers but not always
because that's where the supreme court
in israel sometimes intervenes and says
wait a minute
this land has been expropriated from
private palestinian ownership
this land you can't build on but then
the government has refused to implement
the supreme court rulings
which is why one of the things to look
at and worry about next week in the
israeli election
supreme court was not honorable
how long did it take is it still the
home's there the home is still there
the homestead supreme court and hold on
i'm sorry look
i i i i talked earlier about trolls of
the game
i expect i expect no no i'm sorry i
expect british rules of the game
british gold rules of the game are not
whole organic rules of games
i mean i expect to to honor the truth
you are
spreading life here okay well you'll be
able to sorry
no no sorry both of you sorry no no
daniel really because we'll be able to
um we'll be able to
deal with some of this in the summing up
speeches but i i did say that this was
a question and answer session is the
microphone over there now working it is
hooray the very patient man
who um has been trying to speak to us
all evening
i propose to you that um israel
is not a democracy it is a ethnocracy
because only one race has rights in
israel
and the law of return you know only
grants the rights
to people with jewish blood going back
going to israel
who have never been there and building
on
palestinian land and it doesn't right
give any rights to the palestinians to
even
uh uh have extensions to their homes or
it denies unbelievable things
is there is there a question which do
well basically
it is and it's not an ethnicity not a
democracy
okay thank you okay um
we have somebody up on the gallery
um the most interesting point of her
this evening
is the um the argument about israel
being a democracy which
in principle i think we um most agree
with
and the comparison with the south uh
south africa during apartheid
now um if i may make another comparison
it's a question for the panelists
against
the motion um i was wondering if you see
any comparisons with
what israel is currently doing to the
palestinians
with what the nazis did to the jews
and specifically and uh one more down
here
um we've got a question at the back
excuse me i haven't finished
a question excuse me i wanted to i
wanted to qualify my
my quest it wasn't a statement it was a
question understood uh but we've we've
heard it thank you no
no i wanted sorry i wanted to qualify it
i just wanted to say
it wasn't to be polemic about the
holocaust it took
two aspects of my comparison one is the
fact that the nazis also got voted in
democratically just as much as the
israeli
right-wing governments get voted in
second all the nazi ideology
was founded on fear of the jews just as
much as the arguments i've heard tonight
about the survival of israel based on
fear of the arabs attacking okay thank
you we will
no we thank you very much we've we've
got the tenor of your point thank you
you sir i find in these difficult issues
that historical context is often
very helpful a question for each of the
panelists
which of you has read edward saeed's
book question of palestine
right um let's um
i'm glad that it was the panelists
rather than the um chairman there so i i
don't have to display migrants
um
let's hear from um perhaps william and
caroline this time
briefly um is israel a democracy or not
are there any useful comparisons to be
drawn
uh not just with south africa but with
the nazis and have any of you
read edward saeed
well the answer to the last question is
yes
the answer to the first quest two
questions is more
complex is israel a democracy i suppose
a simple answer to that question from my
perspective
is which israel and israel on
1967 borders or in israel that as we saw
on the map
covers the whole of the west bank and
control
of gaza if um if israel
is the latter it's hard to see it as a
democracy
because palestinians don't get to have
the vote in israeli elections now you
might argue and say well israelis don't
get to vote in
palestinian elections but as we know
palestinians
when they have elections their
governments don't tend to be recognized
the second question was the parallel
with the nazis
and uh i think the parallel you were
using i hope was nothing to do with the
holocaust it was to do
with fear and all those kinds of things
i'm always very
very uncomfortable with anyone making
any analogies
to the holocaust and the nazis i think
it's deeply inappropriate
and i don't like to make these kind of
historical connections
i hope i've answered your questions you
have with admiral brevity caroline
so regarding uh edward saeed i didn't
read his book but i did heckle him in
1990.
um as for um as for the issue of uh
was it uh israel and nazis oh shame on
you
shame on you shame on you let me just
give you a little historical background
which you may or may not know and
actually i don't really care what you
think
but uh just so people know there was the
founder of the palestinian nation was a
guy named
hajime hussaini he was the mufti of
jerusalem that the british
appointed in 1920 and he was a nazi
agent
and among other things that he did
he established in 1940 the hanzhar ss
division of bosnian muslims
and among other things that the hanzhar
division did
was they liquidated the bosnian jewish
community or 90
of it they killed 12 600 jews out of 14
000 jews in bosnia
um this was a man as well who uh
intervened with himmler and with
eichmann to prevent a prisoner swap of 4
000
jewish children uh in in
and yes so basically hajime hosseini was
a nazi war criminal not that you care
about this but it's interesting that
just last week
mahmoud abbas who is the moderate
plo chief and palestinian authority
leader hailed hajimina hosseini as
the hero of the palestinian people in a
speech in ramallah okay so
you know i think that when you're making
when you're making a comparison
excuse me when you're making a
comparison we need to get more questions
people the people the victims
of the nazis and their palestinian
agents and their palestinian apologists
including
including
mahmoud abbas who wrote a phd thesis for
the oriental mu
university in in moscow denying the
holocaust and claiming that it was
a joint plot of the zionists and the
germans and you compare
us to them the perpetrators the people
who now they want to commit
genocide against just read hamas charter
you have some serious moral issues that
you need to deal with yourself
okay caroline thank you very much indeed
can we just get one final
brief group of questions and then we'll
take the uh
the final vote um the gentleman in the
uh
glasses just here in the middle
william and daniel are very disingenuous
in that they
choose selectively to show maps of the
of israel as it currently is it's it
currently occupies 16
of the mandate for palestine
77 of which was given away by the
british totally in contravention of the
agreement
the agreement still stands because under
article 80 of the un
all agreements adopted by the league of
nations are still excellent
so you're actually completely wrong why
is it
that as caroline alluded to it's okay
for jews to be shipped out wholesale
from wherever they happen to be from
iraq from
egypt from syria from lebanon how many
jews are there now
and yet transfer all and from
judea and samaria it's okay to transfer
a wholesale half a million people
but god forbid there should be ev ever
any movement of any other people's
okay you know at the end of the hang on
at the end of the second world war
the end of the second world war germany
lost
i think we've i think we've got to the
point of question
thank you very much indeed uh we've got
um
somebody with a sort of blue sleeve here
green
um i'm a little shocked by some of the
comments from caroline in particular um
i just i will ask a question just for a
bit i haven't heard anyone suggesting
that all jews need to be
removed there is a difference and i
between jewish people living a place
and what settlements represent in terms
of
um the control of the land the control
of movement in terms of the
expropriation of resources
when i've stood on a hilltop and watched
um palestinian water systems being
destroyed
okay do you have a question yes i do
have a question
my question is if it's
all right for settlements in their
current form i don't mean for jewish
people to live in the west bank but if
in their current form you think that
it's all right for settlements to remain
and expand and develop
what is your proposal for the
palestinian people who are living in
area c
and areas a and b we haven't talked
about oslo whole other debate
but in the whole of the west bank what
are you proposing actually happens to
them
thank you very much and uh let's have a
final question from the balcony i'm
gonna try and be
brief at the beginning of the debate i
was asked to
empty my mind of any preconceptions i
tried to do that
and as someone who is not jewish or
palestinian
and may have some idea about the
conflicts and the problems that go on
there what am i supposed to take away
from this debate because
i have to say franklin i'm a bit
confused and i'm i'm actually i feel
like i've been
bludgeoned over the head because i'm not
intelligent enough to understand some of
the points here and i
just i actually came here to learn but
what do you want me to take away from
here
this that's an excellent question thank
you
okay
i'm going to plead for
concision um and also
for us not to raise our voices
but the the three questions were
um why is it not okay for jews
apparently to live in certain places um
what will be the long-term future for
palestinians if settlements
stay in place and why is it i
if i can just paraphrase your very
heartfelt question
why is it so often that when it comes to
discussing
israel the blood boils
well it's a very um interesting array of
questions and uh i can't answer the last
one tim
um but i think that the ladies
question from the balcony is perhaps the
most salient and the most important
and i i speak as i say as a as a brit
and as a non-jew and therefore to some
extent
i'm i'm i come from her state of mind or
i did 10 years ago when i first got
involved in this conflict
and i can tell you that i have the most
extraordinary privilege
of anybody in this room which is i get
to meet
the leadership of everybody on all sides
and they're not many people who are
allowed to do that and the one thing i
can tell you
is that if the palestinian leadership
were offered a two-state solution based
on 1967 borders probably with some land
swaps
they would bite your arm off it's as
simple as that
that i am lucky and privileged enough to
have discovered for myself
it is very hard in a very shouty noisy
both debate here but internationally to
get people quite to understand that
uh the um so that i i hope is a
sort of a point of information but to
the lady up there
who wanted to know what to take out of
this and i think
that um those blue points on the map i
showed you earlier along
are getting in the way of that thank you
very much indeed uh danny i want to ask
you um what is the
long-term future for palestinians if
settlements
not just continue but continue to expand
okay first of all i apologize if
in some instances i lost my temper and
broke the rules of the debate
i think that what makes me my blood boil
is not
the issue of israel but the inaccuracies
of fallacies
but i should have shown more restraint
now and of course again i must say
the the the outrageous comparison to the
nazis
that i i am quite surprised at stay calm
by the way prime minister david cameron
was also elected in democratic elections
and
sometimes he spread fears of the eu
does it make him a nazi i doubt it
um danny what is the that's it it was as
absurd as that
what is the long-term future for
palestinians now i will answer that
look you can be
happy or frustrated by it
but it is still a fact there is no
point that reconciles
the minimal requirements of israel and
the minimal requirements of the
palestinians
how do i know it because prime minister
olmert
gave the more most far-reaching offer
that he the any prime israeli prime
minister can give to mr mahmoud abbas
by the way the u.s secretary of state
condoleezza rice
writes in her memoirs that she couldn't
believe her eyes
when she saw the offer and abbas
rejected it
so for the don't go backwards no no
no no i go forward so we have to
understand that for the time being
we have to improve the situation on the
ground
vis-a-vis human rights vis-a-vis freedom
of movements
vis-a-vis the fact that my daughter
shouldn't be
shouldn't have to go to school in a
bulletproof
bus and no palestinian child should be
threatened
the same way on the long term
and now i go into speculation
my i i suppose that the
solution of the conflict will be
peculiar as the conflict itself
um i suppose that it will be original
one
i suppose that someday it
may be tomorrow or maybe in 50 years
there is going to be an inevitable
change of regime in jordan
because monarchies monarch is not like
your monarchy monarchy
in which the monarch actually rules are
a primitive way of government
there are going to be two nation states
a jewish israel and the palestinian east
of the jordan
with joint responsibility
and joint control of judea and samaria
jews will jews will be ruled by israel
and have israeli citizenship
palestinians
will have will be ruled by the
palestinian state
i suppose the last estas remark
this may be a pattern of government
that doesn't have yet a name in
international relations in political
science
but if you confine yourself to
conventional forms of solving conflicts
and governing people
you will never solve this conflict danny
thank you very much indeed
um uh daniel wants to say something
very very very brief
i mean my my takeaway and it was
predicted
by important israeli leaders at the time
in 67
is that occupying another people for 40
plus years
has a terribly morally corrosive effect
on the occupier of course it's it's not
a picnic for the occupied
but but i do think that that has come
out this evening
that that the need to justify the
unjustifiable
the need to do those somersaults in the
air when one doesn't have a grounding in
being able to justify something
it has an effect and it's a tragedy of
israeli society today that i hope we can
still turn around
and that i hope this isn't the direction
we're going in okay
um
one sentence i actually like i mentioned
i'm writing a book now um and
it's called the israeli solution and my
solution is simply to allow the
palestinians to apply
for israeli citizenship i don't see any
reason
why that shouldn't just be the long-term
future that this will be
one state and the palestinians will have
the right to be israelis
just like everybody else thank you
listen we're now um going to ask you to
we're now going to ask you we're not
going to ask you i'm sorry but we're
running out of time we will be kicked
out of here we're not going to ask you
to cast your votes
um while
you are casting your votes
um we're also going to have
very brief summing up speeches
um really rigidly
two minutes um from each of you and
we're going to be taking it in
uh the reverse order if i'd be very
grateful if you could just
be quiet for the summing up speeches
which we will take in reverse order so
we will begin
for two minutes and i when i start sort
of hammering on my glasses the two
minutes will be up
uh with caroline caroline glick please
thank you very much thank you very much
and just keep going ahead with your
voting
i just want to say one thing you know
danny mentioned that zionism is a jewish
national liberation movement and it is
and um it is based upon the proposition
that the jewish people have rights
we have right to determine our own lives
we have a right to sovereignty
in our land this like this right was
was recognized under international law
that recognition has never been
abrogated as the young man said
in the uh in one of the later questions
this evening
and really what we're talking about here
i think
in this whole idea of whether israel has
a right to assert its rights or not is
whether or not
jewish rights are conditional on other
people's approval of them
and so i'm here to tell you that they're
not they're not conditional on anybody
else
giving us approval for our right to
determine our own existence as jews in
our land
and israel is democracy it's the only
democracy in the middle east
and our people will continue to
determine
our future as a people in our land
and we hope very much that you will
support that
but if you don't support that that's
okay that's all right
that's just fine with us because the
whole point
of having a jewish national home and of
having a jewish state in israel
is for us to be able to determine our
faith
regardless of what others think because
for two thousand years as an exiled
community and dispersed throughout the
world we didn't have that
we didn't have that and we lived at the
mercy of others
and at their pleasure and that's over
it's done
it's done thank you very much caroline
thank you
daniel two minutes
to to singularly say
we have rights others don't
it's at the expense of others only we
have national self-determination
not the palestinians but
but the idea that we can
dwell alone as a nation in the modern
world the idea that all of us
can live unconditionally there's a we
enter into social contracts
every second of the day when i cross a
road because it's green
i'm in a social contract with a driver
who's not going to run me over
to think that israel can exist outside
of the real world
ignoring the fact that all this great
independence that we've just heard
asserted
is only made possible by the support of
the united states
which is going to which is going to
which is going to turn on us with those
kinds of opinions look you could say
we had nothing we got balfour we got
half of it in the partition plan a bit
more then we got 78
and now we've got 100 we can keep it all
i think it's a misreading of israeli
and regional and global realities what
worries me
is that rather than the people with
those opinions
winning an election and implementing
those ideas and discovering
rather quickly that they can't work and
allowing us to move on
that we're going to continue to play a
game where drip
drip drip we move in that direction
without ever
ever stepping back and asking ourselves
how does this end well what is the
strategic objective
where are we going that's why i've
spoken in favor of this motion tonight
[Applause]
well the difference
between daniel's words
right now and mine is only one
that he
presents us with a new topic
with an utopic a portrait of
reality and i'm looking at reality
as it is
the fact is that the
palestinian state does not does not
exist
even today because
of the moral and the political decisions
made by the palestinians themselves
it's not history it's as close as 2008
is as close as 2010. i was in washington
in 2010
when prime minister netanyahu
chairman abbas and president obama
started the negotiations
a month later chairman abbas
found the pretext to leave the
negotiating table
now how can you make do an agree
reach an agreement under those
circumstances
the i beg you to
see the situation as it is do you know
who was the american president
that made the most damage in the middle
east
the american president with the best
intentions
bill clinton bill clinton assumed power
in 2000 in 2000 in 1993
with the stable middle east he thought
had this
kind of romantic vision
of what can be achieved in the middle
east
went to gaza convened the can david the
summit propose the palestinian state
raised expectations and arafat
the result was that yasser arafat made
he
the end of his administration the most
chaotic middle east
that ever existed that is
an example of how misunderstanding the
situation in the middle east with
very liberal views and very i am am i
liberal too
by the way i i i refused to visit south
africa
until the apartheid regime was toppled
okay
yes that's a fact we'll have to leave it
there in order to be
fair william two minutes thank you very
much
more and more israelis are against
making peace
because it's no longer in their economic
or political
interest to do so already the leader of
jewish home
naftali bennett likely to be the second
or third largest party after the
election
has said that there could never be a
palestinian state and he wouldn't ever
countenance forcing a settler out of his
home
where's his taking israel well you've
heard you can sense it
and the truth is that if the two-state
solution
a state of palestine alongside a state
of israel does not appear or can no
longer practically appear
because of the facts on the ground there
will be irresistible pressure from the
international community
for israel to accept as the south
africans had to that the state of israel
will have to become a bi-national state
that includes all the palestinians
with equal rights and in a democracy
that puts the jewish population into a
minority
and means the end of the zionist dream
and even if
a future israeli government decided to
surprise the world
and make a dash for a palestinian state
on borders that the palestinians could
accept
could that government organize the
necessary concessions
from an israeli public and system of
governance that increasingly is made up
of senior settlements
each announcement of further settlement
approvals by an israeli government
removes any remaining doubts amongst the
international community
about israel's genuine intentions
towards peace
or of their intentions to the
palestinians
some trapped in gaza and others in that
archipelago of islands i showed you on
the map in the west bank
that will have enormous ramifications
for israel's future
that is the conclusion of none other
than shimon peres the president of
israel
only a few days ago it's also mine
thank you very much
thank you very much uh william uh you
actually had 3.1 seconds to spare
um uh i should say that um
in uh wrapping up the question and
answer session
i was guilty of yet another filthy lie
by a journalist about the
middle east in that i said that the
reason we had to wrap it up was because
we were going to get kicked out of here
actually
that's not entirely true um
we do have to wrap up the debate and i'm
now
filling for time before i get the uh
results of the vote
but in fact there is a paying bar here
until quarter past nine
and in um uh proper
journalistic fashion i'm encouraging you
all to go to the bar and spend your
pennies
uh the other thing that i would um say
as well is um yes there are books to be
uh had there including um
many of williams um that um
uh the organizers of this debate have
asked me just to
to say that they deliberately did not
ask palestinians onto the panel because
they wanted it to be a debate
uh israelis and jews and those
interested
in israel about israel
so that was the point and that has
brought
me to the um
to the golden globe moment um where i
um tell you the result of the debate but
before i do that
thank you all very much for
your patience and your attention and
your
thoughtfulness just actually to turn out
on a cold weekday evening
to hear all this in the end after
listening to the speakers
for the motion israel
is destroying itself with its settlement
policy
517 against 99
undecided after all that 31.
so thank you to you thank you also
very much to intelligence squared for
another very
intelligent debate safe journey home
you